do you think that you would have a civil
war are you worried about that what do
you think will happen if we do nothing
you've anymore kids will be killed more
churches our court keeps allowing states
to ban assault stop your inability to do
even the common-sense stuff really
frustrates me a string of high-profile
mass shootings over the past few years
has spawned a movement it's calling for
new legislation to outlaw so-called
assault style weapons in particular the
popular ar-15 assault weapon bans are
depicted as life-saving common-sense
policy the problem is that the
definition of an assault weapon is
totally arbitrary the assault weapon is
whatever is covered by an assault weapon
ban Jacob solemn is a senior editor at
reason who writes about gun policy the
criteria that are used to identify
assault weapons are things that have
little or nothing to do with how useful
or how deadly an assault weapon is in
the hands of mass murderer we will
finally ban these assault weapons from
our street the federal government banned
assault weapons in 1994 when President
Clinton signed a bill sponsored in the
Senate by Dianne Feinstein mr. and mrs.
America turn them all in the bill
expired 10 years later but Feinstein is
sponsoring a new version of the law
meanwhile seven states in the District
of Columbia have enacted their own
assault weapon bans there's little
evidence that the 1994 legislation
reduced gun deaths in part because it
was mostly a symbolic gesture unless you
really delve into the specifics of what
these bills do you don't understand how
utterly arbitrary they are in the
original 1994 bill and in the new
version of the legislation assault
weapons are not defined by what they do
but by how they look Feinstein's current
bill talks about things like pistol
grips adjustable stocks threaded barrels
in other words you can have a gun with
any one of those features it is now an
assault weapon exactly said the same
done without those features is not an
assault weapon and in fact there are a
bunch of examples
like that let's compare the Ruger
mini-14 ranch rifle with the ar-15 one
looks like a hunting rifle and the other
looks like a military weapon a fire at
the same rate they fire the same caliber
of ammunition and because they have
similar barrel lengths the ballistics
are almost identical now those are
single shots if I wanted to fire this on
full semi-automatic all I do is keep
firing another misconception is that
so-called assault rifles or automatic
weapons fire continuously until the
trigger is released or the gun runs out
of ammunition the federal government
bans the manufacture of new automatic
weapons for civilian use in 1986
most modern civilian guns are
semi-automatic which means they only
fire one round per trigger pull but if
you're talking about you know how many
rounds can you get out of the gun within
a certain amount of time
any semi-automatic is going to fire be
capable of firing the same number around
originally built for the battlefield a
defining characteristic of the ar-15 is
the speed and power of the bullet
another myth is that assault weapons are
more powerful than other guns in reality
the power of a firearm depends mainly on
the cartridge not the gun again let's
compare the Ruger mini-14 ranch rifle
with the ar-15 both can shoot the same
two to three caliber bullet at the same
velocity you will see that lots of
hunting rifles are more powerful can do
more damage you know at the same
distance than so call the Sullivans one
of the most common cartridges used for
hunting is the 308 Winchester which has
more than double the impact force when
compared to the ammunition used in an
ar-15 another common refrain is that
assault weapons can inherently fire more
rounds than other guns before reloading
but it's the magazine which is just a
detachable box and a spring that
determines how many times you can fire
and many guns that are not identified as
assault weapons except high-capacity
magazines again this is not a feature
that distinguishes assault weapons from
other kinds of guns banning guns based
solely on appearance is countered
octave and it makes it difficult to have
a good faith discussion about effective
solutions to gun violence I'm not gonna
say everybody has to own an ar-15 cause
it's such a great gun but people have
their reasons for wanting to have them
and the government shouldn't be second
guessing those reasons without a very
powerful justification the justification
offered for banning assault weapons is
virtually non-existent because it
doesn't make sense